è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sonova dj oggi stiamo per provare
un qualcosa di un po diverso dal solito
mi è capitato soltanto una volta li farò
un video con la crus rift su una giostra
mettiamola così loculo swift da
veramente tantissimo il senso di nausea
nelle situazioni dove ti trovi nei
videogiochi ma siccome mi state
chiedendo in troppi di fare le montagne
russe con loculo swift [ __ ] niente
ragazzi facciamo sta minchia di montagne
russe
ciò la rosa mi comprata la citrosodina
les chiaro la [ __ ] ecco è bello ciao
ciao mamma che è che le chicche merda è
una nuova all'interno donne che skyrim
ciao fratello piccioni semi cagati in
testa giuro che appena scendo mi lancio
la carriola la prof
che belle protezioni sembra la sedia di
mia nonna sulle rotaie raggrumate bravi
adesso io sulle matt no no no no no no
no scattavo porca [ __ ] solivo oddio
famiglia napoletanissimo lo sapevo io
non sono neanche qualcuno sulla sedia
come cazzo è possibile st goti io mi
tuffo mi tuffo testa la scarsa mica che
brutta cosa ho fatto non ho mai non lo
farò mai più ciò 55 bigazzi
ma perché hanno fatto le montagne di dio
o pazzo e va bene grazie
certo tre volte sono beccato la tenda in
faccia fantastico bravo rossi c'è rossi
c'è però chi volo perché sta volando
[Musica]
va bene sono meglio io e ragazzi nati
figli è orribile
non farò mai più una roba del genere
stato figo è stato figo due etti di
pomodori grazie direi di cambiare
giostra se siete d'accordo interesserà
sapere che giusto un poco prima di fare
questo gameplay mi sono mangiato un
hamburger grosso così per dare un giusto
sapore a quello che finirà nel mio sesso
dopo questi giochi realtà virtuali di
sta minkia la causa che assistiamo su
helix che sarebbe un'altra montagna
russa credo diversa piazza applaudita
deficiente grandi bravi ad ora quando e
stoffa ammazzo tutti gli schiaffi c'è
anche di prè che applaude bravo va beh
[Applauso]
ciao mi chiamo fa vj sono un gran figo
guarda ai ragazzi partiamo prima che mi
sia più a fisca troppo il culo non so
seggiola di ferro
sì sì applaudite che tanto vi ammazzo le
famiglie a dio che brutto oggi è
prontissimo a catania 6 paura regi di
affari jc ben cristo
ti prego che alzo le mani tocco qualcosa
albero è una scusa mi sto toccando le
dette ragazzi è bruttissimo
ciao bella [ __ ] allora dio mio dio sì
certo ragazzino mito anche la cena di
tre anni fa di natale me la ricordo
ancora gli occhi e bresaola l'ha fatto
mia nonna ce l'abbia fatta ce l'abbia
fatta
bye bye no no no no no no no no no
affanculo chiedervi se così brutto gesù
no non c'è dune senso la giostra perché
no no no no no no no no tua madre frutta
ma che palle
hai fatto basta quanto da tempo quanto
dura sta merda nola con l'acqua noailles
mi sono lavato prima sono vivo mi è
venuto da tutti mi sono ripreso subito
una roba guarda se avete un no cruz
prima o poi se l'avete mai non provate
l'ho mai bruttisima ragazzo applaudì con
gli anni di scarto oppure la suocera
adesso che ho dato prova di coraggio
mele fi toccare di cazzo non ce la
faccia perché non ce la faccia ma ciao
bella gnocca monti innamorare di quello
che di fianco perché ce l'ha piccolo
giuro non credo che qualcuno si chieda
come faccio a saperlo
no ma sii serio col cazzo
il figlio ma la fermata romanica parte
così no no no no no no no spiazzavo va
bene voglio scendere voglio scendere ok
basta posso usare le scale usiamo le
scale grazie a voi che siete con me
luridi stronze almeno moriamo insieme
vero ragazzi
ciao mamma si ferma sul cazzo ma sei
sempre dio non so più dove dovevo
guardare lo guardarmi nel culo ma regali
no no no no no no no no no porca [ __ ]
che brutto ragazzi vi invito uno per uno
a casa mia e lo provate non si può
capire da un video impossibile non lo
posso toccare canzoni non ci tenevo più
di tanto e basta vi è finito grazie è
stato bello eh basta basta basta meno di
chi sapete fare le montagne va bene ok
potate le aiuole che fanno cagare
acquisto vuole l'autobus che prendo
parlando alla scuola regga più brutto
questo non è che non ho mai fatto amica
che cazzo non conforme io voglio il mio
avvocato
che roba è
tra i vasto scherzando sto per morire
[ __ ] la vita
fatemelo michael h
basta per me va bene così devo andare da
un medico dai chiorda ragazzi compiono
sugli episodi è stato orribile
dovevo farlo uno sulle montagne russe
perché me lo state chiedendo da quando
ho preso loculo street quindi lui secoli
il pam nell'età della pietra quindi
ragazzi non mi chiedesse di farlo perché
non ve lo posso spiegare quanto è bello
dovreste provarlo lascio perdere per
adesso perché sono mi sento vino
esageratamente male e niente ryan sparo
che video vi sia piaciuto quello che
episodio è chi mette mi piace a vito
ragazzine vita a casa così prova locus
perché non lo voglio più mi fa schifo
però che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa il
tuo seguito è piaciuta lasciato commento
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook che
covano dividono trattano descrizione
sera se avessi iscrivetevi cibo diavolo
fosse una vita bella ragazza